we need to have a complete review of
business rates altogether it is a
perverse system that often really does
impact small businesses hard and I think
we need to look again in terms of having
a land Valley tax system or a system
based on on revenue turnover rather than
on the on the rental values the problem
is all this is going to cost money and
we've already got our social care crisis
or crisis in the NHS well it's all going
to come from well I think it's going to
be a rebalancing away from some of the
bigger companies of course not don't
forget this is the government that has
been consistently reducing corporation
tax and that often helps some of the
biggest companies most of all so that's
look at the bigger companies paying a
bit more so that the smaller businesses
the businesses that a city like Brighton
absolutely depends on are able to
prosper and thrive because they are the
ones who are really the wealth
generators the generators of jobs I'm
case to talk to you about brexit now in
the House of Lords defeated at the
government this week they backed an
amendment to the brexit bill that would
guarantee the rights of EU citizens
living in the UK what do you think it
says about the level of scrutiny
provided by the House of Commons that
this is happening in the laws instead
well I think it's a damning indictment
on what happened in the House of Commons
and I think what we've seen is a
complete absence of robust opposition on
this issue the tragedy was that labour
essentially although they put forward a
set of very good amendments also said
prior to doing that the come what may
they would support the triggering of
article 50 so as soon as they'd raised
the white flag on that as soon as they
had given their unconditional support
for triggering article 50 come what may
any leverage they might have had to get
those amendments passed was completely
gone and as a result you know we've had
the House of Lords being the ones who
were standing up for the right of EU
citizens to remain the House of Lords
were likely to be standing up for proper
scrutiny in the Commons that is farcical
what we should have is a real opposition
coming from Labour working with the
other opposition parties myself the Lib
Dems the nationalists so that we can
have a common position because if we had
that we could have stopped this extreme
brexit for which Theresa May has
absolutely no mandate so you blame
labour then for effectively rolling over
and allowing the government to get their
way on braixen completely blame labour
rolling over and backing the government
I except of
what's the outcome of the referendum
says that we are leaving the EU but
there is a wealth of difference between
a soft brexit where you could remain
part of the single market where free
movement could continue where you've got
social and environmental protections and
the extraordinarily extreme brexit the
cliff edge brexit that the Prime
Minister is currently pursuing without
any opposition coming from the official
opposition the things though some people
will look at what you've just said and
think well you just have benefice or
lose that you're not accepting the
results of the referendum where people
voted to leave the EU people certainly
voted to leave the EU and that's not in
question but the issue of whether it was
an extreme brexit or a softer brexit
wasn't on the ballot paper and if you're
taking the Prime Minister seriously when
she says she wants to bring the country
together well there are four nations in
the United Kingdom to voted to remain to
voted to leave so one might argue that
if you want to try to keep the country
together the best way to do that would
be to pursue a softer brexit that would
mean that you could actually bring
people together in a much more effective
way let's talk now about the future of
your own party because the Greens
they're bumping along and about 4% in
the polls they were supposed to be this
great left-wing uprising with people
like Bernie Sanders in the u.s. picking
up votes but you haven't benefited from
that and why not well don't forget that
1.3 million I think people voted for the
Green Party in 2015 in a voting system
which is absolutely inimical for smaller
parties so in spite of the fact that
most of those people knew that under
first-past-the-post they weren't going
to an elected green party person 1.3
million people still voted green in 2050
you don't seem to have built on that
base though do you I think we are let's
not forget just to come back to the
voting system for just one second
because I think it is so instrumental to
what we're talking about if we'd had a
system of proportional representation
1.3 million people voting Green could
have led to somewhere between 20 or 24
MPs that would have been a very big
difference and I think now what we're
seeing is more people actually looking
twice at Jeremy's leadership because for
whatever reason unfortunately he's not
been able to deliver that the kind of
radical change that he'd talked about
and they want a party that is consistent
about what it stands for and that will
be very clear in its opposition to
government policy on everything from the
business rates hikes through to brexit
through to for example infrastructure
that the min
labour supports Heathrow expansion it
supports Hinkley the nuclear power
station it supports HS - you know it's
the greens that are providing real
opposition suggesting a different way
forward based on green energy based on
local transport links and so forth do
you think that the problem is that if
you're left weighing your vote for
Jeremy Corbyn and if you want to stop
brexit your vote for the Lib Dems so
what's the point of the Green Party the
point of the greens is first of all I
would challenge both of those are
assumptions that you've just made but
the point of the greens is that you've
got consistent leadership on policies
where you know where the party stands on
everything from nuclear weapons to
nuclear power through to real investment
in green energy through to the kinds of
jobs that you could get if you insulated
every single home in the country
bringing people's fuel bills down
creating hundreds of thousands of jobs
addressing climate change
you'd have true sustainability at its
heart there as well so are you looking
to make alliances then with other
left-wing parties knots and
installations for example this is a
question that I think is rightly being
answered at at local level so there may
well be some local areas where there's
sufficient agreement and trust between
the different parties to have a
situation whereby perhaps one party will
soft-pedal or another party may perhaps
stand down but it's absolutely down to
the local level to decide that and for
us for the Greens the big prize for that
is about changing the voting system you
know we've just recently had the the
referendum where the rallying cry was
taking back control I think we should
start by taking back control of our
democracy and are those conversations
going on already with parties like the
Lib Dems or even with labour certainly
at a local level lots of those
conversations are going on and the think
tech Compass is acting as a kind of a
moderator if you like a chair of many of
those meetings and up and down the
country these issues are being debated
because more and more people recognize
that with first-past-the-post their
voice doesn't count they're looking at
labour and recognizing that frankly
whoever the Labour Party leader is the
chances of them winning an outright
majority the next election is
vanishingly small so instead of fighting
amongst ourselves is there scope for us
to be working together on certain issues
and if there is I think it would be
irresponsible not to not to actually
address that you've talked a lot about
the voting system which clearly doesn't
help
party's like you're wrecking the thing
that I often wonder is do you find it
quite lonely being the only green MP in
the House of Commons I'd certainly like
there to be more alongside me that's
that's for sure but actually what I do
find is that what's possible is that you
can work with other MPs from other
parties around issues of shared concern
and so for example we've just managed to
get through now an agreement from the
government that they would introduce
statutory personal social health and
economic education I'd put down a
private member's bill on that issue but
I've also been working with MP's right
across the political spectrum to really
push the government on that and I think
actually what it means if you're if
you're on your own
you have to work well with others and
that's how you get things done